[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing two of the most important
characters
in the entire harry potter series
dumbledore and voldemort
by the time the books begin dumbledore
and voldemort already have quite an
established relationship
both acting as the magical powerhouse
for their respective side
in the wizarding power struggle however
voldemort and dumbledore go
way back as it was dumbledore himself
that first visited voldemort
in wall's orphanage revealing to him the
magical world
and helping to normalize his magical
abilities so that he could feel that he
was
part of something in the half blood
prince we see dumbledore visiting
voldemort through the pensive
and it is in this moment that we first
get a glimpse the troubled young boy
that was destined to wreak havoc in a
magical world when dumbledore shows him
magic for the first time
he's in awe and it's not long after that
the dumbledore formerly invites him to
hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry however at
this point in time
voldemort went by another name tom
marvello riddle
with tom coming from his father tom
middle senior and marvolo coming from
his maternal grandfather
marvolo gaunt the truth is that before
even beginning at hogwarts
tom knew that he was different he caused
massive amounts of trouble at the
orphanage where he lived and he could do
things that other children couldn't
triggering an identity crisis of sorts
because tom was conceived via a love
potion
he was incapable of feeling certain
emotions like love
and this was ultimately one of the main
reasons that he went down the path that
he did
as he grew older riddle in a cloud of
darkness began to obsess over his
identity
and where he had come from he started
researching his family history
and eventually came to understand his
relationship to hogwarts founder
salazar sylherin he also connected the
dots and was able to figure out who his
blood family members were
this eventually brought him back to
little hangelton the same town that his
father
tom riddled senior as well as the gaunts
lived riddle
angered by the way that he and his
mother had been treated ended up
murdering his
in his own words filthy muggle father
and this truly cemented the dark path
that he was to follow
after returning to hogwarts riddle ended
up setting the basilisk
loose on the students of the school and
it was at this point that he had fully
adopted his new name lord voldemort
intent on putting that part of his
existence behind him entirely
he created his new persona in order to
escape his past
and start anew tom hated his name and
loathed when it was used
however one man the same man that found
him as a troubled young boy in a quiet
orphanage
never stopped using it the name
voldemort is of particular significance
to his character as
broken apart to vol de more it literally
translates to
theft of death or flight of death in
french many believe that this choice of
name is in reference to voldemort's
evasion of death
via the use of horcruxes by splitting
his soul into pieces
voldemort effectively achieved
immortality subsequently stripping death
of the capacity
to take voldemort's life force or soul
the very name
voldemort incited fear in the hearts of
wizard kind
a well-earned reputation on voldemort's
part through incessant acts of tyranny
and murderous tendencies however his
name also seemingly had power beyond
that
power that no other dark wizard had held
over the general population
wizard kind feared uttering the dark
lord's name entirely which resulted in
workarounds like
you know who and he who shall not be
named but
why was it so powerful many have
speculated that the practice of saying
you know who and other workarounds in
place of voldemort began
during the first wizarding war and it's
all because of something called
the taboo curse the taboo curse is a
particularly powerful bit of magic
as it is able to designate a word as a
key that reveals the speaker's location
this meant that whenever voldemort's
name was uttered it would alert death
eaters and snatches to the location of
the speaker
a good example of this taboo curse in
action is in the last book
when the trio are camping and harry says
voldemort's name out loud
this ultimately causes them to get
caught by the snatchers shortly
thereafter
being taken to malfoy manor so
unsurprisingly
most witches and wizards did not want
that happening they didn't want to deal
with voldemort
snatchers or death eaters makes sense
however
my issue with this is that dumbledore
was always such a strong advocate
of using his name my dear professor
surely a sensible person like yourself
can call him by his name all this
you know who nonsense for 11 years i've
been trying to persuade people
to call him by his proper name voldemort
professor mcgonagall flinched
but dumbledore who was unsticking two
lemon drops
seemed not to notice it all gets so
confusing if we keep saying
you know who i have never seen any
reason to be frightened
of saying voldemort's name i know you
haven't said professor mcgonagall
sounding half-exasperated half-admiring
but you're different
everyone knows you're the only one you
know all right
voldemort was frightened of so why did
dumbledore
taboo curse and all encourage people to
say voldemort's name
was he purposely endangering people the
following exchange between harry and
dumbledore helps to illustrate this
sir said harry i've been thinking sir
even if the stone's gone
vol i mean you know who call him
voldemort harry
always use the proper name for things
fear of a name
increases fear of the thing itself as we
can see here
the reason that dumbledore wants people
to call him by his new name voldemort
is because he wants to take away the
fear associated with it
in dumbledore's view the fear associated
with voldemort's name
only increases his level of power and
influence by openly using his name
and getting others to use his name this
overarching fear is taken away
and would likely result in more people
joining together to stand against him
voldemort thrives on inciting fear in
the hearts of witches and wizards
and without that same level of fear his
power is stripped in a way
all voldemort ever wanted was to be
special powerful
out of the ordinary and that's part of
the reason that he got rid of his old
identity
so what you may ask is the best way to
strip him of that new power
acknowledge him as if he never changed
as if he was still the same little
confused boy in the orphanage
tom voldemort never liked any of his
names and was very open about it from a
very young age
in the half blood prince riddle even
says to dumbledore very irritably
there are a lot of toms with an act of
taboo it's hard to ignore the element of
fear
associated with the name however the
truth is that if everyone were to say it
and it became commonplace then no one
would be any more targeted than if no
one said it
at all it's shaky territory particularly
if you find yourself feeling brave
and ahead of the curve but it's a
necessary risk
however despite encouraging people to
use the name voldemort
dumbledore himself would often call
voldemort by his real name tom
not only did this strip him of his power
but it annoyed him to no end
as in voldemort's eyes it was blatantly
disrespectful to the transformation that
he had undergone
in my eyes i think that it would have
been more powerful if dumbledore had in
fact encouraged people to call him tom
or tom riddle instead of voldemort as
this would have humanized him
the very thing that voldemort always
tried to escape the problem with this is
that not many people knew that voldemort
was in fact
tom riddle voldemort was a well-known
name across the wizarding world
tom riddle was not and to try to educate
everyone on his former identity
instead of simply leveraging his new
identity may have been a wasted effort
additionally i would imagine that a
large consideration for dumbledore
would have been voldemort's awareness
regarding the security
of his horcruxes if dumbledore had
openly discussed voldemort's childhood
name
it would have placed attention on his
upbringing more specifically
the aspects of his upbringing that may
be related to his horcruxes
the last thing that dumbledore would
have wanted is for voldemort to become
extra protective of them
as this would have invariably made his
defeat much more difficult
and that's it for this video if you guys
have any questions about this or
things to add then comment them down
below until next time
there is no good and evil there is only
power and those
too weak to seek it who said that
comment down below
you